I found out something very surprising
about our show this is true a new report
just came out I find this out a couple
of hours ago
a new report found that my show has more
Hispanic viewers than any other
late-night program in a related story
what else mis amigos telemundo afternoon
but i can all your soy un gringo muy
Blanco we we Blanco it's my school and
oh that's right oh hello who are you
I saw you there okay alright I'm doing a
monologue I forgot where I am and who I
am of course the big story is rush
limbaugh
you've all heard about this Rush
Limbaugh has lost 12 advertisers now
because on his show he called a woman a
[ __ ] and advertisers are dropping out
yeah today a o L joined a long list of
companies that have dropped Rush
Limbaugh to the latest AOL yes folks
present for a Oh L said we would have
done this sooner but we are using AOL so
imagine the problem
a little over the weekend President
Obama contacted the student that Rush
Limbaugh called a [ __ ] and offered his
support yeah then President Clinton
phoned her and asked is it true
[Applause]
Hill who today Rick Santorum took a
swipe at Mitt Romney by saying money's
not gonna buy this election
two hours later Mitt Romney bought Rick
Santorum six thousand dollars hey this
is surprising big surprise
Vladimir Putin won his election in
Russia
yeah kidding no he did must have been a
nail-biter yeah it really was
the choices were Putin or you die yeah I
kill you after winning Russia's
presidential election Vladimir Putin
began to cry during his victory speech
yeah in other words Putin is now the
president of both Russia and wussie Stan
vans liked it more than the crowd never
a good sign in that business you're
gonna like this one
why because I'm telling you a couple in
England check this out has paid
thousands of dollars to get their dog a
facelift they got their dog a facelift
yeah apparently the dog was so ugly
other dogs were sniffing his face
[Applause]
[Music]
a couple was arrested for having sex in
Nebraska's history museum
yeah the couple later apologized and
said you know how it is you start
learning about Nebraska and then one
thing leads to another I love this story
you all know about Google Streetview
'he's well a man in France is suing
Google because they posted a Google
Streetview picture of him peeing on his
front lawn
he's mad yeah yeah on the bright side at
least now we know where Gerard Depardieu
lives
any porn fans here what did you do that
for starting today in LA all porn actors
are now required by law this is the law
in Los Angeles now they're required by
law to wear condoms during all sex
scenes yeah and all and also for some
reason they have to wear crops
I think the law is going too far that
takes me out of the picture completely
really when I see Crocs involved I don't
know it's not erotic to me
[Applause]
now I really want to know what you're
thinking but I'm scared okay I'll move
on